what are your five best tips for someone
to gain a million followers on vine I
don't have any tips for gaining a
million followers I can tell you what
some good habits are to grow but I
wouldn't be able to directly give advice
like oh here's how to get millions but
be yourself be creative like just just
be yourself because what might seem
weird to use some more laughs at like
this someone who I follow on by and they
have almost no followers but I find that
person funny because they're just
themselves and their unique and it just
awkward and I just find it funny so be
yourself because you never know who that
will attract be consistent post often or
frequently if you can so that what
people get used to checking back collab
with people that are bigger than you so
that way you can get new followers let's
say that's three let's do I have two
more I would say that's the top three
yes huh yeah
you